it seems like you show instead of town
where does that come from again I'm
fighting fighting is a lot of emotion
people think or people think it is all
physical and I mean but it's not it's
all mental you know me the same thing
everything everything that I learned
from my competition and I'm still
competing now my competition she's got a
fight in September in Japan and for my
fights so I kind of take everything I
learned from my god like 27 years and
martial arts I take everything i learned
from that and i put it in the inactive
so that's sort of like my my my therapy
like when I one night when I train when
I go to the gym and and I learned
everything for my fight and I put
everything in acting gaming stuff like
that so it's all from fighting you know
so I'm finding that I faced with all of
the emotion because they get fighting is
fighting his emotion there's a lot of
emotion in fighting and his controller
is to control but I think that that's
the main thing it's the control of
emotion it gets angel is range because
that is just like okay I want you to
show this but then this and this and
it's almost like almost like troop in
the story which is why he's going to
play troop in the story he'll wrap it
unfolds like an onion it's just like
yeah he's rough on the exterior but then
he'll show you this and then he'll show
you this and as I didn't know he had
that in him and as and then that's why
he's true in this story because I wrote
trooper certain way and I did it was a
no-brainer I knew it angel could perform
it you know so at least one character I
didn't have to worry about it another
example or was again when when competing
even though you could be hurt arms can
be all broken and stuff like that but
you can't show him that once you go kick
it on guys that you in pain so you have
to act like you laugh and you fighting
and stuff like that but he thinks that
you your Pony things oh he's not hurt
but i'm actually in paint on my
shoulders broken so that's sort of like
a what from fighting that by bringing
two into acting you know I me because I
had happens my had a my shoulder
dislocated one more fights and I'm gonna
corner only paying my Martina gordo
sugar show the show buh buh
I can't go show like I'm gonna call
Pookie foot hurts I don't know he'll I
go show don't show any fear don't show
any emotion gay pcs it is gonna go after
your shoulder so I'll go back in the
third room laughing laughing my laughing
cuz if he hurts you don't know that but
that's what what what I bring
into the acting sucks for all the
emotional fights did you win that fight
yeah one that one yeah we should still
trying to see if we win the big fight
yeah we were hearing this weekend about
poker and I don't know much about poker
but there's I tells and then a lot of
top poker players they were huts the
shades so then you can't see ya can't
see the pupa you can't see the veins
yeah tried smoking then back the same
thing I mean you're fun to me that's
kind of how that's how I interpret is
acting you know I don't know how he sees
when I see it I'm just like you know I
think it's his control over the emotion
that allows him to that that allowed him
to gain control of his acting quickly
and it was that because I again last
shot at redemption that's when I saw
okay the wait was one thing first thing
you know it was one constant a motion
for the wait so that was a good start
for both of us but a Redemption it was
really complex and and what we've done
since then has been really you know
complicated and I've been stretching
them as hard as I can as an actor and he
doesn't break so you know is it's
awesome
you